on parle donc de la guerre d'algérie de
la torture des exactions de l'armée
française et celle du fln
alors est-ce une polémique a rallumé en
tout cas le président de la république a
choisi de le faire en reconnaissant la
responsabilité de la france dans la
torture alger d'un jeune militant
communiste maurice audin et en allant
même voir la veuve de maurice audin
aujourd'hui en banlieue parisienne
c'est le célèbre mathématicien cédric
villani également député en marche qui
est à l'origine de cette démarche
pour lui il est temps de regarder
l'histoire en face en l'écoutant
emmanuel macron et pour moi cette
historique va reconnaître la
responsabilité de l'état dans cette
disparition va reconnaître là que la
vérité c'est que maurice audin faisait
partie de tous ceux qui ont été victimes
d'un système et le président également
s'attachera à faire de ce moment un
moment non pas d'accusation mais un
moment de vérité on regarde l'histoire
en face et on prend bien garde ne pas
jeter le blâme sur tout le monde sans
distinction mais on invite tout le monde
à parler et à panser les plaies
il voit une folle se parlent et panser
les plaies comme le dit cédric villani
il n'en est pas grand temps mais non sur
l'algérie sur la chose qu'il ya une
sorte de jouissance malsaine concernant
cette période algérienne à vouloir
systématiquement relaté les
culpabilisation les claypool il est oui
mobilisation de la france forte qu à ne
voir que la france qui pourrait être
coupable alors que des exactions
il y en a eu sans doute dans l'armée
française il faut les noter mais il y en
a eu également de la part du fln toutes
les exactions des uns des 1re et pas
répondu aux exactions des autres
allaient bien dans cette es d et es
décimétriques or les repentances sont
toujours unilatérale et c'est cela qui
me choque que l'on comble est que la
vérité soit dite
naturellement cela cela va de soi c'est
un rôle distinct rôle des historiens de
dire ce qui s'est passé il faut ouvrir
les archives et il faut dire si les
tortures dire qu'il vient me les
tortures bien sûr mais pourquoi à chaque
fois vouloir faire de cette seat de
vérité ensuite des actes politiques qui
répondent dans le fond à des pressions
de minorités ça ça répond à l'exigence
du parti communiste ça répond ça ravive
la plaie
la guerre d'algérie qui n'est pas fermée
cette paix là elle et elle est encore
vivace et auprès de populations
algériennes françaises qui ont encore
des comptes à rendre avec l'ancien pacer
trop tôt et je sais surtout ceux qui
utilisaient ce que sur ce sujet
repentance ou volonté de faire la
lumière sur un épisode bien précis dois
je sens que c'est une honte
c'était aussi un débat entre français
pas seulement entre français et
algériens ce que maurice audin et les
français et que emmanuel macron je crois
a été voir sa veuve est ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'il a 25 ans et un
jeune père de famille et disparaît et en
fait ils disparaissent c'est à dire
qu'elle se retrouve seule elle ne sait
pas où est son mari est au fond il faut
donc tout 50 ans pour reconnaître la
vérité ça avait commencé à être dit par
françois hollande qui a parlé du fait
qu' ils avaient été tués dans le cadre
de cette ce régime spécial en fait de
détention de rétention qui étaient
autorisées avec des interrogatoires on
avait cette bataille d'alger on est
rentré en 57 et ce qui est intéressant
aussi il faut s'en rappeler c'est que
déjà en 1957 on a des militaires comme
le général de bollardière qui s'opposent
à la torture dont il ya déjà des débats
en 57 entre français et donc moi je ne
reverrai pas en fait aux algériens
d'ailleurs que les algériens n'ouvrent
pas leurs archives et ne reconnaissent
pas forcément leurs responsabilités moi
je trouve que c'est l'honneur de la
france de reconnaître la sienne et que
c'est un débat entre français que ça
concerne quelqu'un il s'agit de
reconnaître les fêtes
est ce que je regretterai juste c'est
que ça ait pris tant de temps et que ce
soit emmanuel macron qui le fasse
aujourd'hui parce que du coup c'est plus
vraiment à mon avis l'occasion de faire
un grand débat historique ou ou de
réfléchir en termes de responsabilité
c'est plus se reconnaître une
responsabilité à l'égard d'un individu
d'un jeune père de famille qui a disparu
et c'est terrible on ne sait de ne pas
savoir où est passé où sont passés les
10 par nicolas vidal c'est un sujet pour
vous ça alors de la france débat entre
français que comme le dit lucie cuite ou
repentance inutile moi je suis d'accord
sur un premier point effectivement la
france doit affronter son passé
il faut aussi rappeler le contexte
historique
gerry duplain mon ami de la bataille
d'alger en 1957
on rappellera aussi que c'est le
gouvernement socialiste qui a demandé
que l'armée remettre de l'ordre et gérer
immédiatement dans le sens du vent
reyhofen effectivement la france va s'en
passer c'est une chose mais on ne peut
pas garder sur le passé que les choses
qui ont des périodes de noir de
l'histoire de france il faut aussi la
france a une histoire séculaire et on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui enlever certains
grands héros et puis et puis après nos
gardes et ne faire que le focus sur des
éléments qui ont été tragiques de la
guerre d'algérie c'est une chose et je
pense qu'effectivement c'est toujours
compliqué aujourd'hui de regarder
l'histoire sous des sous des aspects un
peu
voilà un peu partisan voilà c'est mon
ami marc landré vous avez on a vu que le
sujet ait rapidement maintenant point de
vue vous dites moi j'étais pas né je
suis pas nager dépanner et donc j'étais
tanné le président de la république
l'était encore moins ce qu'il est plus
jeune que moi je connaissais pas cette
histoire je connaissais pas maurice
audin je pense que comme une ultra
grande majorité de français
on découvre ça aujourd'hui et surtout à
la réflexion que je fais c'est que ce
seuil à 60 ans je dis pas que c'est pas
important je dis pas qu'il faut pas en
parler mais c'était à 60 ans et c'était
un autre temps
c'étaient d'autres moeurs était d'autres
pratiques d un autre monde on n'a pas
connu la guerre
moi j'ai pas connu la guerre en algérie
je pense que peu de personnes encore en
france ont connu des périodes là il y
avait des choses qui se faisait qui ne
se font plus aujourd'hui qui se pouvait
justifier ou pas je pense que c'est le
rôle effectivement des historiens que de
d'ouvrir les d'ouvrir les pages de
l'histoire et les historiens mais pas
des politiques et pas des politiques ça
ça sert à quoi pas grand chose à mon
avis et je veux juste rappeler quelque
chose ce que disait on en a jamais parlé
ici pour moi je vais faire le premier
jean jacques goldman dans une voie qui
s'appelle né en 17 à leidenstadt ils se
demandent dans cette chanson qu'est ce
qu'il aurait fait lui si en dix sept
îles et télé l'autre côté de la barrière
il y a pas été français il était né
allemand et que 30 ans 20 ans après
parce qu'il avait été il aurait été
rendue mise arables il aurait été
défaits par l'armée française
il aurait pas eu cette envie de
vengeance voilà moi je ne sais pas ce
que j'aurais fait je sais pas comment
vivaient les gens à alger à cette époque
la dic ce que faisait les français la
torture on sait qu'ils en avaient le pen
l'a dit qu'ils l'avaient torturé cette
époque-là en algérie on le découvre pas
aujourd'hui le dossier odin il a été
emmené m
tic de la cause de des indépendantistes
et des français qui étaient de leur côté
donc c'est vrai que c'est encore à fleur
de peau lucile schmid sur ce côté ce
qu'il faut pas fermer effectivement la
page maintenant comme le dit marc 60 ans
après marc a raison de souligner le côté
en algérie c'est pareil je ne sais pas
quel est le pourcentage des algériens
qui ont moins de 25 ans mais c'est
beaucoup plus qu'en france donc c'est
peut-être autour de 50 60 % donc
effectivement ce sont des fêtes qui sont
ignorés d'une grande majorité les
algériens plus qu'en france
et chez nous c'est vrai qu'on s'est
repenché sur qui était maurice audin on
a pu se le demander mais moi je trouve
au contraire que c'est plutôt bien c'est
à dire que moi j'ai le sentiment que
j'aurais préféré que ce soit fait avant
peut-être quand ceux qui l'ont vécue
pouvait se dire tiens oui ça me rappelle
quelque chose mais je trouve que prendre
conscience du fait que ça a été un grand
débat notamment que les catholiques ont
joué un rôle très important au moment de
la guerre d'algérie y compris les les
appelés pour dire moi je ne veux pas
torturé il ya eu quand même des cas
emblématique et ce qui s'est passé en 57
c'est qu'au moment de la guerre la
bataille d'alger les choses se noue avec
des français qui était en algérie
ensuite ça a été repris par des
intellectuels ça a été plus abstraite
quelque part dans les années 60 61 quand
c'était de gaulle qui était au pouvoir
est en revanche en 57 ya eu quelque
chose qui venait du terrain et donc moi
je trouve que c'est assez superbe
j'ai un point de vue assez inverse
peut-être parce que c'est lointain qu'on
puisse ça me semble être un truc
démocratique qu'on puisse revisiter
notre histoire et y compris reconnaître
que la disparition de quelqu'un même
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec lui
politiquement c'est quelque chose de
terrible et qu en démocratie on peut pas
faire disparaître les gens et la torture
entre nous ça continue à exister
beaucoup dans le monde
enfin un mot là-dessus je ne sais pas si
je ne pense pas que la france rios sa
bouilloire systématiquement battre sa
coulpe irez le voir systématiquement
dire que c'est elle qui est coupable
en plus ici en accusant l'armée
j'attends d'avoir les réactions de
l'armée que c'est l'armée française que
l'on désigne comme étant comme étant
coupable dans le fond c'était peut-être
à l'armée française d'avoir à faire son
beurre sur le dos j'ai audace sans
rentrer dans les détails un débat sans
fin mai
plusieurs et notamment le général
aussaresses avant de mourir avait
reconnu la responsabilité de s'étonner
que les fans et les faits étaient connus
c'est pas ça juste précisément il y as
je vous retrouve une sorte de de plaisir
malsain à vouloir à nouveau aider le
président de la république actuel avait
déjà des 10 de la colonisation qu'elle
était un crime contre l'humanité pendant
de la colonisation algérienne et donc
que l'on continue à vouloir absolument
se battre l'aso à vouloir s'écorcher vif
devant devant ce qui donne réellement
jubilent à nous voir souffrir
or je pense pas que 7,7 cette posture là
soit une posture qui ruine qui nourrit
hausse mais c'est une posture qui nous a
baisse mais semble-t-il dire qu'elle est
vue par ceux qui nous regardent comme un
acte de faiblesse régulièrement et je
pense que la république ne comprend pas
la grande ambiguïté du message qu'elle
peut passer en tout cas à ceux avec qui
elle est censée s'adresser c'est à dire
également aux algériens et aux
communistes
les communistes maintenant question et
on pourrait peut-être dire trois mots
des crimes communistes et puis les
algériens aujourd'hui qui nous voit à
chaque fois vous allez dire que c'est
effectivement nous qui avions tort parce
que moi je moi j'ai beau mot gt5 je suis
né en 52 je me souviens très bien de ses
épaules j'étais petit mais je me
souviens très bien quand même de la
violence qu'il y avait dans les rues
d'alger de l'intérêt c'était vraiment
des violences qui était très largement
symétrique de voir asymétrique si l'on
parle vraiment de la violence des faits
laisse donc la parole à nos internautes
parce que c'est les résultats de notre
question alors qui encore une fois n'est
qu'une question à nos internautes
approuvez vous la décision d' emmanuel
macron de reconnaître l'implication de
la france dans la mort de maurice audin
le résultat est assez partagé 54%
d'entre vous estiment que non
vous ne pouvez pas cette décision mais
résultats d'assez balance équilibrée
justement vous faisiez l'allusion
maurice audin l'a dit militant
communiste évidemment alors certains
tout de suite voit une récupération
politique d' emmanuel macron à la veille
même de la fête de l'humanité ce
week-end là dessus s'il suit
non je crois que ça c'est trop
paranoïaque je pense que effectivement
je crois que le sujet c'est pas sûr
valoriser ce qui est en train de se
passer
pour ça que moi je parlerais plus un
acte individuel à l'égard de cette veuve
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre de l'humanité à son égard
et vous savez ceux qui ont l'impression
d'être subi qui ont subi une injustice
forte aussi parfois les dossiers
individuels permettent de fermer des
choses est de démontrer mon nez mais il
ya moi je pense que là ça me fait pas
fermer quelque chose en écoute juste sur
le plan de l'effectif demander des
arrière-pensées politiques marine le pen
qui était l'invité du toc avec yves
thréard ce matin au figaro elle s'est
peut-être un signal lancé aux
communistes ou alors juste avant la fête
de l'humanité
mais encore une fois cette et ça va
évidemment avoir comme conséquence de
rouvrir des blessures puisque on le sait
monsieur gaudin c'est vrai à cacher a
caché des terroristes du fln qui ont
commis des attentats qui ont fait des
blessés et des morts dans les familles
françaises
donc je pense que c'est un acte encore
une fois qui est un acte de division
politique peut être politique
nicolas vidal juste un commentaire sur
le dessus moi je serais pas aussi
manichéen que
que versatile que marine le pen je pense
effectivement je reviens cette première
idée c'est cette idée aujourd'hui de
mettre en exergue toujours ce qu'a fait
la france
il faut toujours affronter son histoire
c'est évident mais de là à en faire de
l'enfer cet acte de contrition permanent
et de dire non mais vraiment sur la même
ligne avec les voiles à la repentance
aujourd'hui me paraît un peu plus
idéologique voilà et sur l'ouverture des
archives parce que là aussi c'est dans
le débat de d'ouvrir tout tout de suite
le plus possible oui si effectivement si
ça peut être rendue publique que les
historiens ça puisse enrichir le travail
des historiens il avait raison
d'ailleurs on rappellera que ce soit
rien là dessus sont pas tous d'accord
sur les skis d'hommes et lg
il ya beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de
zones dans cette histoire-là ouvrir des
archives ouvrons les archives mais les
dés sont effectivement les historiens
dans une pleine possession de leurs
moyens et et voilà je pense que c'est
important je suis aussi d'accord